and what does a hitman at a Mexican
cartel do you get you you take care of
the Dirty Work you know that means going
into cities and locating these uh these
rival Hitmen these rival people or rival
drug drug lords and taking them out so
when you're working as a as a CIO
obviously there's there's rules that you
cannot pass if you want to keep yourself
alive because it's a very dangerous game
never get high with anything that they
that they move in order for you to keep
yourself on guard and on point on what
you're doing obviously the people that
that would do drugs you would see them
lasting 3 months 2 months they would end
up getting murdered